[Music]
hey you guys
it seems kind of brighter in here than
usual
the camera's [ __ ] up the camera's not
[ __ ] up it's just the uh i'm in the
wrong spot you're in the wrong spot and
also that bathroom door is open and the
sunlight is coming in through the window
yeah it's bright in here which is uh
yeah weird
i kind of like it dark so you can't
really see my face
[Laughter]
see i'm just gonna start combing my hair
forward like causing it
that's what i'm gonna do
but uh yeah so hi everybody it's monday
and today we are talking about
eyes of laura mars yeah
it's a pretty good flick man this is a
carpenter flick sort of he didn't direct
it but he wrote screenplay although i
will say that like it went through a lot
of changes yeah like after yeah like you
know i guess most of the time they do
but
you had not seen this right now
i was impressed it's kind of an all-star
cast even though everybody people in
this probably weren't all that famous
during the time oh they absolutely were
famous uh faye dunaway had actually just
won an oscar on her prior film which was
network yeah um
tommy lee jones had been he wasn't like
a mega star but he had been in several
things
yeah so he was young in this yeah he had
a unibrow too
oh yeah a big time yeah that bony old
hair you thought that i was imagining
the unibrow because the first time he
came on the screen i was like wow way to
make that unibrow work for you tommy lee
i thought it was just
he's got a bony ass head you know what i
mean it looks like
i don't want to say he looks like a
neanderthal but he's got a real strong
brow ridge he
looks like a down werewolf or a vampire
or something and i thought it was just a
shadow but no that [ __ ] had the
unibrow went all across it but you know
that's just how it was and we'll see in
the 70s that would have been like too
feminine to actually like tweeze your
brows i'm a man i don't want to tweeze
my brows yeah
although they had makeup on them
well yeah just you know well like i said
it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any guidance
obviously but i'm just saying that's
probably what what they would have
thought of no real manly men should be
all hairy we we don't do that we don't
pluck had the dude that played gomez
from adam's family one and two raul
julia yeah he was he was a youngster in
it too
i think he got this part because he
lived in the same building as
one of the other actors i can't remember
which one but he's basically like hey
they're cast in this movie why don't you
come be in it and he came and got in it
there's a whole bunch of people in it
that uh if you see him you go oh it's oh
he's in it or she's in it yeah yeah and
um i liked it it was good about this um
new york fashion photographer and she's
having visions
but they show her like uh
her at work and doing photo shoots it's
just [ __ ] crazy
it's like late 70s slash early 80s
looking fashion
they're [ __ ] turning cars over on
their downtown new york turning cars on
their sides and setting them on fire and
doing a
ridiculous photo shoot
all of new york watching like back when
that was back when a photographer was
important back when they had fashion
magazines and [ __ ] i think well and you
could actually and you could actually
list like shoot in new york city like
back then back back when a photographer
could make money
well some did and actually the the
photographs in this were actually based
on the work of a real photographer like
a german photographer helmet newton so i
was saying you know yeah back then there
were they didn't have an internet you
know they only had one media there's a
print and a television and a little bit
of radio and if you could make a name in
either one of those three that was it
you were making millions of dollars
you couldn't do that now
we've got all kinds of fantastic
photographers they're just on the
internet
well yeah like i said back then it was
much more expensive to get into it just
like movie making right like everything
else uh yeah slasher fred points out
this movie also stars actor brad dorf
yeah
yeah he had actually he was uh also not
a mega star although he had been in one
flew over the cuckoo's nest prior to
this uh and he got i think he got an
oscar nomination he was in he was in the
old dune he played [ __ ] mint at
piedra vereese there's a [ __ ]
hardcover
voice of chucky voice of chucky's also
he was also in um
exorcist three
fantastic very underrated role there
yeah on exorcist three
which is a masterpiece really i love
that movie it's a good movie yeah i like
that it's gotten like a critical
reassessment because i kind of feel like
it got i mean exorcist two can kind of
suck a dick that was kind of terrible
but um but the third one's the third
one's awesome yeah it's really good it's
a it's like a good standalone
yeah you don't have to have you even
seen the first one it's not really all
that important no but um yeah so the
interesting thing about this which i
actually had completely forgotten about
i saw this movie a bunch of times on
cable back in the early 80s because it
seemed like it was always on yeah um so
i had seen it a bunch of times and i
remember really digging it like it was
like kind of creepy uh i didn't know
like in the early 80s i didn't know
anything about giallo movies but this is
essentially an american take on a giallo
film
uh you know kind of because you know
it's set in like a high fashion kind of
world and it's a good glamorous and
stuff like that so it's kind of very
similar with the pov shots and whatnot
so uh what ended up happening with this
was that the thing that i had forgotten
was that the original spec script for
this was written by john carpenter yes
that's john carpenter
what happened was after he had made dark
star
he had actually written two spec scripts
one of which was assault on precinct 13
which he obviously went on to direct and
one of which was a sort of neo-noir
giallo slasher movie called eyes
now he was actually going to direct this
but what ended up happening was that
there was this guy who was like the
he was like hairdresser to the stars but
he had like a [ __ ] ton of money and he
had made like a lot of connections
through fixing everyone's hair
and he was also dating barbara streisand
and he liked this script so much that he
essentially bought it from john
carpenter
as a starring vehicle for barbara
streisand she was actually supposed to
be in this yeah now as it came out
i guess what they tried to do i think at
first they were kind of trying to like
go in like a more romantic thriller kind
of direction as opposed to like a horror
thriller direction i kind of got the
idea from john carpenter the way he's
talked about this that initially it
started out as more of like a slasher
movie kind or more like a giallo movie
where
the where the killer was just kind of
like some nobody it wasn't really like
it was just like a random person because
he thought that was scarier
which is not how the uh movie ended up
going
what ended up happening was that when it
started going back into the more horror
direction
barbara streisand didn't really want to
do it because she thought it was like
too lurid or grotesque or whatever and
she's like she don't want to do it but
she did contribute uh the song which you
actually like that song don't you yeah
that is actually a good song it's called
prisoner um and uh the song at the
beginning and that's actually about the
movie yeah that actually did uh pretty
good on the charts
uh but yeah so she don't want to be in
it so they had to find another actress
and uh they also brought in
a you know a guy to do the rewrite on
the script who actually turned out to be
david zelig goodman who was the same guy
that wrote
logan's run
and what the [ __ ] else he also wrote
straw dogs
uh so they brought that guy in to kind
of like redo it
and then they were kind of like looking
around for different actresses i think
they were maybe goldie hawn would be in
it maybe like a couple other people
but they asked faye dunaway and like i
said faye dunaway had just won an oscar
so
and this was kind of like a lower budget
that's not like a tiny budget but it
wasn't low budget yeah but it was kind
of a little bit more of i don't want to
say it was an indie flick necessarily
but it was kind of a more independently
finance flick yeah it's definitely not
not a mainstream movie yeah but it's
like a high end
in a weird way it's kind of like a
high-end horror suspense type
thing
almost [ __ ] romance it has a sexy
element to it it's very seventies
but it's high-end it kind of feels like
you're watching the exorcist one
kinda i mean it now
exodus just kind of had a gravitas to it
yeah this has that even though
the tone is very different just you just
got to see it shot really well i liked
how it felt like i said it it very much
is like an american take on a giallo
film and i've even called this i think
even at the time like some of the
critics called it the disco giallo yeah
which i thought was very funny thank you
very much sticky marks what do you say
anything okay no it's just a it has it
has a very uh sex appeal angle to this
movie but it's still cut
i don't want to say the slasher it is
kind of a horror suspense type psycho
thriller kind of yeah i mean that'd
probably be a good way to put it it has
paranormal [ __ ] in it
yeah it's basically like a psychic kind
of yeah you know so it reminds me of
like a jello but with a little bit of a
psychic thing in it like that lucio
folgi movie which is called the psychic
a lot more a lot more coherent than an
italian giallo movie though it's got a
very coherent edit
yeah like this one it's much you know in
some ways like the plot twists and stuff
like that are just
are kind of the same but yeah you can
follow the narrative like a lot
easier it's got a real good score
a lot of good-looking people in there
you know they got a lot of hot model
chicks and [ __ ] and [ __ ] dunaway
looks fantastic and [ __ ] tommy lee's
doing his thing and it's just brad dorff
in it [ __ ] acting like a freak it's
it's good it's good it's a very
entertaining movie although brad dorff
acts fairly normal yes fairly normal he
was funny if funny he's not playing a
comedic role
but the [ __ ] that he says comes off his
phone you just have to see it yeah
this was actually direct here's another
thing that i didn't realize this was
actually ended up being directed
uh by
irvine kirchner the same guy that
directed
the empire strikes back yeah okay like
the year after this and in fact it was
this movie
that made george lucas go hey i want
that dude to direct empire strikes back
so this this is at the nexus of like all
kind of things that were happening
man i'm recognizing talent and i just
it's it's a very uh
good movie to watch it it does keep you
in the movie it goes all over the place
a bit but it is still coherent
it's kind of like a journey through the
19th what was really [ __ ] cool in the
1970s mixed with some paranormal stuff
so in a way very much like a jollo
uh yeah it's it's structured pretty much
exactly like but very american
yeah yeah like i said it does have that
glamour that high fashion glamour and
everything like that
um yeah so what the story is like i said
is that faye dunaway she plays laura
mars she's like a really famous
fashion of photographer like i said
she's very very well known like not only
like her shit's in like galleries and
stuff like that but it's also like in
all the fashion magazines and in ads and
whatnot
so uh her thing though
and i don't know i don't know if it's
like implied that she's always done art
like this or if it's just like a new
direction that she's going in but she's
gotten really into
photographing and like i said this is
based on i think his name's uh helmut
newton who's kind of a famous
photographer who would do kind of like
these fashion shoots but set up like
murders kind of thing
uh because there was kind of a thing for
that so so she's been like exploring
that in her work but
she's getting like all this blow back
because they're like well do you think
you're glamorizing violence and you know
violence against women and stuff like
that so people are kind of like getting
on her tits about it and
uh you know so they kind of go into that
a little bit it's not like super
heavy-handed or anything like that like
it's not some big
theme of the movie but there there is
kind of
that at the beginning where she's at a
gallery and everyone's kind of like
[ __ ] on her about you know don't you
think this is irresponsible or blah blah
blah yeah there's some hints of
bestiality and [ __ ] going on in the
[ __ ] photographs but see i remember
when there was a lot when there was a
lot of high-end photography was going in
this direction yeah yeah it was it was
kind of going to kind of crypto perverse
kind of way yeah the whole the whole
fashion angle of the movie actually has
that very 70s love motel feeling to it i
i still liked it it's kind of
you know if you
if you were growing up during that
during that time you remembered the
spirit of that time when you were a kid
it was it was good times [ __ ] kind of
hedonistic but you know just the way it
was now um
oh and german also points out and i
forgot to mention i'm sorry it is that
uh renee aberjenois was uh in this as
well trey trey simmons says that uh says
i remember the trailers for this were
creepy as [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] of me
when they yeah it was eight says yes
[Laughter]
and you're like eight or nine you can't
really [ __ ] make you don't know what
you didn't even understand a subject
matter you know what what's it talking
about yeah what it was very vague and
sinister sounded you knew that murders
were happening that was it and some eyes
were glowing
she could see it
yeah because that's essentially what
starts happening is that they don't
explain why it happens or what or
whether she could do that before it's
obviously this is a new thing that she's
developed maybe since she started doing
these more violent photographs but she
essentially starts seeing
through the eyes of
a murderer is what's going on because
what ends up happening is that she's
been taking all these pictures and then
she's approached by
uh the character john neville who's
played by tommy lee jones and he's like
the lieutenant who's in charge of the
[ __ ] and he basically brings her in and
says um
here are some unpublished police
photographs of all these murders that
have been going on uh you know nobody's
seen these and yet they look a lot like
photographs that you've taken almost as
if you've seen them and you're restaging
it and she says that she
she doesn't really want to say because
nobody wants to say i'm having psychic
visions of the [ __ ] because everybody
will just be like yeah right you are
this is the kind of [ __ ] that i grew up
with man this is the 1970s you still had
parapsychology being taught in in
universities it was like a higher
evolved spiritism from the early 1900s
late 1800s
and your parents all when my parents and
[ __ ] relatives believed that all this
was
possible
which this set up the environment that
happened with me with the [ __ ]
mammoth mountain
now who knows
i'd have heard that that kids and young
kids may be more open to
what they call psychic experiences or
what the native americans call the
spirit world and [ __ ]
um maybe because
they i don't think i've heard that
little kids kind of naturally produce a
certain amount of dmt
which
can give kind of spiritual
awareness or sensations of spiritual
knowledge now maybe in the 70s because
of them the hallucinogens and the drugs
and [ __ ] and maybe that
in the adults and
might have been some kind of synergy
maybe people were naturally producing
dmt
and having
poltergeist events and [ __ ]
clairvoyance and dreaming true and
it was i believe i remembered that stuff
people talking about it a lot more than
they talk about now
and i had my experiences
and maybe it had something to do with
the pre-internet era where people were
more moving inward than outward
maybe the indians were onto something
you know
maybe it's just naturally produced dmt
you know [ __ ] getting you in tune
with the other dimensions
but just food for thought
movies like this actually cause certain
[ __ ] to happen
in people because
belief is a very powerful thing
yeah i mean i kind of feel like this one
um
it's not like overtly supernatural but
it does have like yeah i mean basically
all she's doing she doesn't really know
what's going on until a little bit later
she just kind of thinks while she's
taking pictures but she gets these
visions where she seems to be looking
through someone else's eyes maybe the
the taking of the pictures and all this
artistic exposure and her
is getting her [ __ ] juices flowing
her psychic abilities flowing
which in science maybe maybe she's
starting to produce dmt and stuff and
have spiritual awakenings
maybe that's what they're getting at
with with the whole fashion photography
angle plus it gives the movie
uh
the chance to show hot people
well yeah like i said that was kind of
like the whole thing about giala movies
too and that's why the italians made so
many of them
is that we can set it in all these
glamorous like a fashion house or you
know all this other stuff or you know a
girls school or whatever or dance
academy and uh then we can show like a
bunch of hot people in various states of
undressing everyone's a winner yeah so
people don't pay money you're getting
asses into seats that's what i mean
that's what it was about and also you
get to see them horribly murdered so you
know that's more asses
and there's like a large crossover
between those two things which like i
said i kind of feel like that's sort of
where this was coming from as i said i
don't know
john carpenter like later went on the
record of saying this was really not a
great experience for him because the
original script that he wrote
um he said i'm paraphrasing but he said
the original script that i wrote i
thought was very good but then it got
shat upon quote unquote so i'm not
really sure how much they've changed it
it is still very much like a giallo
but
one thing that's really interesting that
they do in this film is that unlike
italian jealous which are all about like
the stylized violence like you know
let's see like a knife plunging right
into like a human heart you know what
i'm hitting with blood spraying
everywhere like they were very into like
the operatic the violence just very
graphic this one kind of like cuts away
it doesn't really it sometimes shows
like the aftermath but it's not real
violent or bloody oscar said he just
went and saw the damn trailers and
understood why it would scare me as a
kid and then he said that's an
unreliable narrator i don't know [ __ ]
he's talking about
i don't know if i could talk about this
i actually watched the trailer earlier
today because i was watching
um there's another channel called good
bad flicks and he had done uh kind of
like a half hour
breakdown where he was trying to get
more people to watch this because you
know he thought that it was
unappreciated i haven't seen the trailer
since i was a kid in the [ __ ] movie
theaters and [ __ ] back when i was like
eight so if i if i don't remember it
correctly then you know then [ __ ] y'all
i i just remember her eyes glowing and a
voiceover and there may have been more
than one
edit of the trailer too because a lot of
times they had long ones and short ones
depending on how long it was running on
television yeah and i remember
[ __ ] being scary and [ __ ]
mean i don't know what it was about
really
honestly like the well the longer one i
think the one that i watched earlier
today was the longer cut because it had
a lot of scenes from the movie it's like
people piss and mode nowadays about
trailers it's like oh they give
everything away yeah go watch some ones
from the 70s
they tell you the whole [ __ ] movie
they're like five minutes long yeah
people would joke back then in the 70s i
saw the trailer
i don't need to see the movie now yeah
they had people saying that i remember i
had kind of forgotten until i recently i
was kind of like on a kick and i was
like i want to see the trailer for this
that the other thing i'm like they gave
away the whole baby the trailer is like
five minutes long and it's like every
single good scene that was in there is
just in there and it's like i mean
nowadays they stop doing that nowadays
they show a lot of stuff from the movie
but nowadays they're smart enough to
kind of like do some misdirection yeah
you know what i mean because and we kind
of talked about this when we were
talking about last night in soho where
it's like if you see the trailer you're
kind of like well it gives the whole
movie away but it totally does not but
to see nowadays they're like aware of
that so they're like they try to do like
misdirection kind of stuff so then when
you go see the movie you're actually
surprised in the 70s they basically just
told you everything that was going to
happen in the movie and uh then you went
and see it and yep yep that's what
happened in the movie that was right in
the trailer but uh but yeah so
what ends up happening is that during
the investigation like all of these
people around her around laura
end up getting killed and she starts
just freaking out like this you know the
killer's gonna come after her or
whatever and um she her and john neville
the cop you know tommy lee jones they
start like falling in love so there's
like a romance thing which is you know
terribly unprofessional but i mean he
even acknowledges that like later in
that he's like yeah i should be trying
to like catch a killer but meanwhile
we're just like making out or what yeah
this is an italian [ __ ] inspired
i'm gonna have to start digging through
those bushes
and digging through those bushings yeah
i like that that's the 70s
yeah
parting the foliage yeah yeah that's
that that's what we're
doing this is 1970 [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah pretty much
so uh yeah so i guess like the first uh
the first person that they think it is
is poor ronald julia because raul julia
is
faye dunaway's uh your or you know her
character is laura mars's ex-husband
and
he's kind of like sketchy like they so
they kind of it's you know it's very
much like a giallo in the sense that
they're setting up all these people's
red herrings
interestingly and i didn't realize this
and i don't even think this is on the
wikipedia page but i saw it like on
another kind of like uh
you know really in-depth breakdown of
this
was that they were actually rewriting
because i could okay so the director and
faye dunaway like super really did not
get along so there was a lot of tension
on the set also they were kind of
rewriting the script as it was going
because when they first started shooting
it
they um didn't know who the killer was
going to be
so which in a movie like this i kind of
feel like that's some important
information because even in a giallo
film even though they set up like 40
bajillion you know
red herrings like every person in it is
is horrible and could be the killer
easily and everybody has a motive
um but at least like when you go back
and watch it
like you know seeds are planted like
which person it actually does end up
being even though it's usually like
super convoluted and weird
but
this one so i kind of feel like
maybe and i don't know like maybe if you
go back and watch this one like the
person who ends up being the killer i
don't know if there's any kind of clues
that are seeded throughout that and i
think that's because they didn't decide
until near the end like who the killer
was going to be
because like i said in the original
script that john carpenter wrote the
killer was not anybody that she knew it
was just some rando because he thought
that that was that was scarier that it
was just like a person that decided to
target her for whatever it's like it was
almost kind of more like a deranged fan
or stalker type situation
rather than being somebody that she knew
you know what i'm saying
but i mean i don't know if i necessarily
want to say what the outcome of this is
it is very geoloey
but um
i don't know should i say i mean this
movie is old but a couple people in
there said that they said that they
hadn't seen it yeah don't read it don't
ruin it so so yeah but other but people
get accused you know so raul julia gets
accused like um brad dorf gets accused
who brad dorf by the way plays her
driver tommy
um and yeah he's great and i actually
liked uh i kind of liked his fluffy ass
hair i don't usually like that fluffy
ass hair get some wild ass was like a
frog it was like a fro and then like he
had kind of like a scruffy beard and i'm
like i don't usually like that look but
i'm like that is that's working for him
i'm liking that well he was young he
could pull it off yeah he was 10 15
years older he when he's looked at i
always love brad dwarf
he's always like the best thing yeah
crazy hair and [ __ ]
facial hair
yeah when you're young you can pull off
some [ __ ] i'm not about it usually
but well see i can't really say that
across the board because it depends it
depends on the person's face it depends
how they're wearing it it just it
depends on a lot of things you can't
just say i don't like that across the
board because yeah like you know you put
you put a pair of like old lady glasses
on an old lady just looks like an old
lady with glasses
old lady glasses on a cute 17 year old
girl looks cute as [ __ ] yeah you know i
mean that's that's that's what we're
talking about yeah that's what i'm
saying it's just kind of like and well
and we were talking actually we talked
about this probably way too extensively
like while we were drunk we were
watching this yeah well maybe i don't
think we were drunk
this is a little bit inebriated this is
a this is a pro alcohol movie
you don't have to be paid a [ __ ]
whole hell of a lot of attention to have
fun with the movie that's true i mean
depending on what movie it is but yeah
this one yeah you just just free flowing
it yeah yeah oh check that out yeah yeah
just showing you stuff but we had a very
long
i remember it being a very long
discussion about tommy lee jones's
unibrow yeah we were fighting over
whether it was there just a shadow
well cause like i said the second he
came on screen i was like oh my god
first i was like oh my god i forgot that
tommy lee jones was ever that young yeah
and then two i was like wow rocking the
unibrow like i said again
not everybody can pull off a unibrow but
i'm like i think he's kind of pulling it
off and then tom's arguing that's not a
unibrow it's just a shadow i'm like that
is absolutely a unicorn and then it
started to
[ __ ] it totally is what impressed me was
but he looked good in it he looked good
at it yeah what what what
one of the things that shot that kind of
shocked me is that he was a good looking
guy um but he's playing a leading man
and that and it was funny because they
showed him without his shirt on and it
was just like how low the standards of
physical fitness were back in the 70s
although he was like a big football
player like only a couple years before
that yeah but you can't tell nowadays
they would never do that they'd have
that put that [ __ ] on cycle you
got to look like a damn marvel superhero
star from [ __ ]
marveled before they were in a way like
it's shitty but i kind of like it
because it's like look women have had to
like endure this you have to look this
perfect like to be in a movie and i kind
of like that now they're doing it to
dudes too yeah i'm like yes well hey man
and that [ __ ] goes that [ __ ] goes to the
action legends of the past like [ __ ]
um
uh you know dude from [ __ ] omega man
and [ __ ] what's his name uh [ __ ]
charlton heston all right
they'd have had chest and run running
around with this shirt off and that dude
just built like a damn box just like a
kite that's what he built like a kite
well like i said
the standards for dudes flimsy i mean
dudes could just get away with like just
looking like a dude yeah you didn't have
to be particularly like handsome you
didn't have to like tweeze your unibrow
right you didn't have to do anything
like that you could just kind of be
charismatic and show up and everybody's
be like all right i suppose so justin
was just tall he had a commanding
presence but he didn't have to work out
to be strong he just whipped your ass
just on pure force i guess i don't
[ __ ] know uh the the only his heston
his hesitantness i guess
and that's another thing that's what
it's not why they never [ __ ] had
clint eastwood take his [ __ ] shirt
off ever because clint eastwood is just
built like a scarecrow he's just there's
no meat on that dude
even in his brain he's very lean bones
yeah he looks like one of those old
cowboys out on the range yeah and a kite
that's just a cowboy and a kite had a
[ __ ] baby just ate beans and coffee
all the time
yeah that's the only guy the only guy
that was really the old school action
dudes there's only really only two of
them that [ __ ] had a decent build one
of them was [ __ ] um
little uh
uh dude from [ __ ] dead wish what's
his name
[ __ ] you know what i'm talking about
yeah dude from death wish charlie brown
charles bronson charles bronson was
[ __ ] he he was shredded um
i don't know if that was natural or not
probably not
oh and then uh another one that had a
natural build who was [ __ ] a badass
though was [ __ ] lee marvin lee marvin
was on d-day and [ __ ] but he had a
soldier background
but um
he was he was pretty he was pretty
physical
captain bolero says everyone needs to
see riff tracks this is hormel on
youtube oh i haven't watched that i'm
gonna write that down because i'm
actually gonna watch that write that
down over there just on this side
uh mr roboto says uh
you could pull off the fluffy hair maybe
me uh perhaps jenny with feathered hair
i absolutely had feathered hair in the
1980s as did everyone it mine wasn't
feathered feathered it was kind of
layered hair was just
came feathered out of the box when you
were in the 70s i mean they whether you
wanted that done to you or not that's
what they would do that's what was going
to happen to you um
like i said mine wasn't feathered to the
sense because i knew some girls in high
school that were like fed and it was
like out here like with the hairspray
mine was just kind of like layered you
know like a shaggy layer
um and then mr roboto also asked tom if
you could go back to the 70s as you are
now would you
yeah
liking right well well i might for like
a day like a day or a week or something
but i wouldn't want i wouldn't want to
go permanently no [ __ ] oh no not to
live absolutely not no but absolutely
not but to go back there for like you
know a couple years or something oh hell
yeah i wouldn't even do it for a couple
years maybe a week it depends well i
think i'd get sick of it pretty quickly
wasn't anything holding me here you
could i could go back there and make a
[ __ ] ton of money i know i well that's
true i can [ __ ]
basically do well you could invest in
all kind of do what biff did out of
[ __ ] that's what i mean like you know
you're like yeah apple computer i'm
gonna invest in that yeah
that was like that was like forrest gump
he's invested in apple because he
thought the logo was pretty right and
ended up or uh there's just a lot of
stuff that you'd be able to call winners
on certain concepts and call winners
well i mean that's kind of that you
wouldn't even have to go back to the 70s
that's just like a time travel that's
just a perk of time travel in general
yeah i'm just saying that and also
having a bird's-eye view of the [ __ ]
culture and knowing what phases are
gonna come next you could
uh you could do all kinds of cool [ __ ]
you could become a damn fashion leader
probably
coming up with some [ __ ] fashion that
hasn't come out yet but you know it's
gonna come out well yeah you could have
just make it so you were in the right
place at the right time and then you'd
be like [ __ ] just check my ass out
you could go to the right place the
right time and know on the cutting edge
where some famous people are going to be
before they're famous and make friends
with them and then they get famous and
now you're famous there's all kinds of
although see but if you do that you're
going to mess up the whole like space
time continuum because we've talked
about that like any time in time
movies
you can mess up everything i think if
you run into david bowie you pretty much
know he's gonna be famous
that's true but i mean him knowing you
might have like unforeseen consequences
that's what i'm saying
uh david june says a trailer that gave
it all away superman three with richard
pryor shitty movie yeah that's what he
said he said awful flick it was kind of
terrible although richard pryor was good
in it but
well it was it wasn't it wasn't either
one of their faults it was that that
script was not that good yeah and the
direction was not good it tried to go a
little bit more of a comedic route and
which is terrible because looking
one of the best things about that movie
was richard pryor and he was a huge fan
of the first one the second one and
and he was really disappointed in that
story you know he he didn't like that
movie or that story oh dear that's kind
of [ __ ]
bad in a way you know [ __ ] pryor
really wanted that to be the greatest
one but even when he was making it he's
like wouldn't that be wouldn't that be a
bummer like if all your that was like
your life's goal i want to be in a
superman movie yeah and then you get
finally get to do it and then like
it had it could have been worse it could
have been worse i had the wrong director
well you know it's like i said that
happens a lot yeah wrong director the
thing about movies and like i said it's
really
um considering and we're kind of you
know getting back to like eyes of laura
mars considering how much trouble this
one went through how many scriptory
rights how many directors how many
actors like you know and there was like
all this tension on the set the fact
that it came out a pretty [ __ ] decent
movie
didn't make a [ __ ] ton of money but it
made its money back you know i mean it
was kind of a moderate hit
but
the thing about movies that is kind of
like different from other types of media
is that there are so many people
involved to get one made
that to be honest with you i'm more
amazed when something comes out good
yeah
like and and the fact that most movies
are pretty okay right and are not just
like a garbage fire that's kind of
amazing according to what prior said
when they pulled him onto the movie and
he's [ __ ] hearing about what's going
on he's hearing the direction he's like
an oh no he's like
because i'm in this movie they're gonna
try to make it funny
and he didn't yeah he didn't want to be
yeah he wanted to play it
prior wanted to play a serious [ __ ]
role in a great
uh superman episode and man just wasn't
the right director donner would have
done it
donner would have made sure i mean as
long as he could have said hey i want to
do i want to
try and stretch and play something not
comedic which is
which that totally would have worked
because look at all the comedians that
went on to do drama like robin williams
for example um that ended up being
[ __ ] great at it yeah well even even
to a certain extent eddie murphy yeah
can play a straight role you know
[ __ ] he doesn't have to be comedic he
played a great vampire i thought he was
great
in vampire brooklyn well that one was
still kind of funny yeah well he had he
had supporting cast his buddies
but he didn't play it he wasn't funny in
it yeah he's played a straight row
and uh yeah that's kind of [ __ ] that
was kind of bad on for
uh i don't know that would suck yeah you
get pulled into the movie and your
presence ruins it
because that's what the director wants
the director wants it to be yeah and
that's well that's another shitty thing
is he probably blamed himself because
he's like oh if i wasn't so funny they
would have just like let me be annoying
yeah and then he kind of got his way
because he's not
being a total clown in it yeah in that
movie he's trying to
be a serious kind of like not really a
villain
because he ended up saving superman at
the end but he was part of the villain's
plan
so he kind of got what he wanted but
because he was in there [ __ ] that
director wanted this [ __ ] to oh we'll
pull in the comedic crowd oh they'll
love it no
that's not what that was a bad wrong and
that that tank that tanked that series
because four was even worse
yeah four was terrible yeah i think what
is it canon films got it or carillo or
one of the
or you know
or whatever i did carol
it's [ __ ] frog bottom some people say
it's fun to watch though because it's
just so [ __ ] bad
i remember it being hilarious but not
for the reasons i got it man it's not
supposed to be somebody sent it to me uh
i haven't gotten around to seeing oh
yeah we haven't watched we watched the
first three but we haven't watched the
fourth one yet yeah yeah him watch four
minutes one night we'll have to get like
super drunk and one time yeah watch that
[ __ ]
but i bet you watch it it's better than
three
just because i don't remember it being
better than that i remember i remember
it being awful yeah and i actually kind
of like some stuff about three yeah you
know what i mean that was actually a
pretty decent yeah it's not a loser it's
a half a hit i just remember four just
being ridiculous yeah like just
ridiculous yeah but i haven't seen in a
long time three could have been awesome
yeah three could have been great it
could have been better than two but it
wasn't captain blair said tom's unibrow
needs to be fire engine red without a
[ __ ] unibrow
you could make one yeah i had to connect
that [ __ ] and then mr roboto said
unibrows are great tommy lee jones was
never young he was though
i thought i mean he'd been in a few
movies prior to this i think
but
i had just forgotten like how he doesn't
look like young young he doesn't look
like he's like [ __ ] 19 or anything
but he looks like he's maybe yeah 30
tops i don't know how old he was in this
but he just like compared i'm just used
to seeing him so rumpled and old and
grizzled that it's like funny seeing him
that young oh by the way um
this is the first time i mentioned it to
you i'll mention it on the show um
kanavatsalan sent me some links last
night they think that they found the
zodiac killer oh i read i heard about
that like a while back they're pretty
sure
but i didn't know like they they figured
out maybe it was the dude's dead so it's
just he died in 2018 or something like
that um i don't know if they have
absolutely dna proof but they're pretty
sure that that might be what it is it
came back that they do have it okay
because like i said i remember reading
something about it like a few weeks back
and they didn't have like dna proof but
they were pretty sure we may want to do
a show on it
yeah we should probably like write that
down we could do like a side tracks on
it or we could do on the regular show
like
a show on it
uh but yeah well we can't do it like
this wednesday because
because it'll be uh we'll do it we'll do
it on that we'll do that properly oh i
have to put it in the in the patreon
poll though all right um camp guy says
new serial killer i just found out about
maury troy travis the videotape killer
out of st louis okay i'm gonna have to
write that down too because i have also
never heard of that it's real isn't it
sad even somebody that like reads about
true crime and [ __ ] up [ __ ] like that
all the time i'm constantly coming
across new [ __ ] serial killers and
that's horrifying that there's that many
but you know
uh there's that whole thing too but yeah
so where did we watch this we want this
is actually free on
amazon prime right is it amazon prime or
hulu it's one of those it's one of those
two things yeah it was good uh so you
can watch it for free i was like
actually really
uh glad to watch this one again because
i hadn't seen it in so long
i forgot too that uh renee abregenois
who played her
laura mars's uh assistant i guess
manager whatever he was
um that i don't think they outright said
he was supposed to be gay but he was
like a gay character so i thought that
was like kind of cool that he was
because i think when he got killed he
was in drag yeah
yeah he wasn't he was wearing like
laura's clothes i was um
i liked it i liked it i thought it was
really good it's aged really well it's
held up um when i saw the carpenter
connection i was like oh really and then
i had totally forgotten you could feel
the carpenter-ness of it as it goes even
though it's changed a lot you know
you can kind of see where that where it
was coming from though it's like it's in
that universe
um
it's just good movie yeah and i mean
carpenter was a big jello fan so i'm
imagining
that his version was probably like i
said even though the killer was like
just a random dude uh was probably like
a lot more violent this one kind of
doesn't it shows like the aftermath of
the murders but it doesn't actually show
the murders happening like an italian
jello movie would so it's not
it's not really really bloody or violent
it was almost kind of like the i think
that was like a deliberate directorial
choice good 70s flick it's [ __ ] kind
of
seedy but classy at the same time yeah
cd classic cd and classy
70s were
yeah that's actually a good sum up of
the it's all like seedy and classy at
the same time yeah and coke fueled yeah
but
yeah
all right so uh i guess we'll wrap it up
for today gotta go get go have a roast
beef damage i think i'm starving but uh
tomorrow we're gonna do like a
thanksgiving special matinee i think was
it you david june i thought you were
here earlier that sent us
thanks killing the little box set
um so we watched those last night and so
uh we have some thoughts yeah so we're
gonna do that as like a thanksgiving
special matinee tomorrow uh because
those will be and i was gonna like
record one and put it up extra but but i
was like no i think it'd be more fun to
like talk about live yeah because those
two movies they're quite great
[ __ ] crazy
and we had such a good time watching
them
the second one which is actually
thanksgiving three i'll explain it
tomorrow um
was one of the i don't know what drugs
they were on when they wrote that but i
really wish they would give me some
because that was one of the weirdest
things i've ever seen but uh yeah so i
guess we'll wrap up this for today yeah
go watch eyes of laura mars it's really
good
and we will see you guys
again tomorrow thanks for super chats
and thanks for hanging out with us this
afternoon bye